en face de toi et de lui
[Musique]
le programme a pour objet de leur
apprendre les techniques de football
mais aussi les valeurs de la vie prendre
le football accessible à tout le monde
et que les équipements les ballons ne
soient pas un frère
[Musique]
avec quatre équipes
le football il est vulgarisé la tendance
à malheureusement changer où les enfants
quittent l'école vers le football se
disant que c'est le seul ascenseur
social pour eux parce que ils ont des
idoles que vous connaissez les parents
ils voient que les retombées les
retombées je dirais financer du football
donc on se dit bon un enfant qui n'est
pas venu à l'école ou bien qu'il devait
partir à l'école c'est de bonsoir de
l'accompagner sur le chemin de football
mais c'est pas il y a pas d'assurance il
y a pas d'action tout risque et la
seconde touriste c'est d'aller à l'école